so I'm about three or four miles from
where this incident taking place that's
in the north of the city I'm smack bang
in the center of munich on one of the
main shopping streets here and I'd say
within the last 40 minutes the streets
have gone from being bumper to bumper
traffic with trams people walking people
doing their shopping people going home
to now the streets are not empty but the
traffic has closed through really a
trickle there no more trams going on the
street there's the odd person walking
around looking somewhat mystified I'm
here in a hotel and the lobby is
jam-packed full of people who've come in
off the street and the hotel isn't
allowing anybody out there not providing
any information but as I saying they're
handing out water to people in the hotel
lobby and there's just a few people as
I'm currently hanging out the window
here looking who is still walking down
the streets there's helicopters
periodically going overhead and there
have been quite a lot of sirens a lot of
police car action as well going first
direction on this main street